all right how are you feeling it's all
about to happen
oh man it's crazy it's crazy
i can't believe it's happening again i
don't even know how to feel right now
honestly
my name's tyler i'm 23. i'm from ohio
uh i live in hit south carolina hilton
head
and i'm a beach lifeguard
well take me back what went through your
mind when
discussion started for you going on big
brother again
for this all-star season in the middle
of a global pandemic
i can't even begin to tell you how
difficult and insane and just like
a roller coaster of a decision this was
to do this
and leave angela behind it was tough it
was
really really tough that kind of warms
my heart because you're not even really
mentioning that it was a tough decision
in the pandemic you're just saying it
was hard to leave angela behind and i
see your tyler loves angela sticker
behind you there
that's right that's right that yeah was
she really the tough decision then
absolutely absolutely the pandemic was
literally just
oh yeah and also there's a pandemic on
top of that but the real hard decision
was
was leaving angela for sure so what
makes that such a hard decision because
she obviously knows what it's like to do
this
and you guys are this love story out of
the show so what made it tough
we are literally inseparable like since
the day we met in the big brother house
we have spent
less than 10 days apart and we do
everything together from traveling to
our business to
literally just eating every meal and to
be torn apart
like this it's not easy but wow we both
knows for a reason
so quarantine was no problem for you
guys you're used to being together at
every minute
yeah exactly we met being quarantined so
yeah it was easy what advice would you
have for couples who
maybe would welcome a break from each
other right now
non-stop and quarantine what makes it
work man
you know just putting the other person
first and
making sure that they're giving that
back to you every day
because if you're putting someone first
they're giving it back to you then
nobody ever loses that's how we do it
angela asked to do all stars
uh no it was just me it's just me
which was like the tough part for me too
because angela's an all-star in my book
but you know i mean it is what it is i
guess
we both couldn't win anyway so
i mean i'm gonna go and try and uh use
it as motivation and
pulling out for for both of us she's my
entire motivation
she say that again she's my entire
motivation in this anyway
so if i win she wins and i'm saying vice
versa if it was her in this position you
know
oh well what was her reaction to the
potential of you going on
she was very excited but sad
and yeah it was just this weird feeling
that we've never really
experienced before with each other it
kind of hit me all at once that like
we're gonna have to be a part for the
first time if
if we go through with this and yeah it
took her
a little bit longer for that to really
hit home but we finally came to a place
where we knew it was the right thing to
do
and it's gonna be a challenge and we
can't tell the future
really but we're optimistic and we're
positive and we don't back down from
challenges
and we don't want to be quitters so so
we're going for it full speed ahead and
we'll see what happens it sounds like
you're going into this thinking
you guys are 100 together when you come
out of this it's just a break and you
just gotta power
through the break and keep her on your
mind oh yeah dude if it was just me
i don't know if i could even do this but
having her
out there makes is gonna motivate me
like if there's a
a tree that they're making me hang on
for five hours like i'm hanging on it
for six hours
you know i have such a deep motivation
inside me to do this for her now
and i know she's gonna be out there
waiting for me when i get out so
yeah i'm excited and the winner is
congratulations tyler you are america's
favorite houseguest
i thought they all hated me i thought
america hated me
no they love you a lot of people felt
like
you really should have won on your
season so
what do you think was your fatal mistake
looking back
i think what i did i tried too hard to
get to the end
and i didn't focus enough on
really locking in all of those jury
votes
like i thought like basically from final
six pretty much
everybody i had on my side and
i thought they wanted to take me to the
end but i just wasn't focused on really
locking in the jury
and i i knew it was gonna be close but
you know it is what it is and i'm happy
i don't
hold any like bitterness to losing
because if i was gonna lose to anybody
it would be casey and i'm happy with
that
but i mean i'm gonna give it a shot this
time hopefully i can pull it out
yo how are you gonna put all these
gorgeous girls in this house i'm trying
to win some money
and you're gonna just distract me like
that haley's pretty hot
angela's pretty hot bailey's really hot
too i'd give him out the mouth to any of
these girls if they need it
any single one so what are you gonna
change up
and are you worried about how missing
angela might affect you mentally in
there
for sure for sure you know last time i
was
100 just focused on the game 24
7. i would go to bed i would have 15
different ideas going through my head
for what i'm gonna do the next day
but that's that's a new layer to this
game that i haven't experienced
i'm gonna have to be connected to the
outside i'm gonna be thinking about
angela all the time
you know and so i'm just gonna have to
work that into my strategy
i'm really gonna have to just focus on
what's in front of me
and uh not go to any dark places you
know not worry too much
but at the same time it's gonna be very
difficult
but what would you be worried about
there's a pandemic
out there and angela is like by herself
you know we're each other's voice of
reason when one of us is sad
she talks me down and vice versa you
know there's a pandemic in
everything man it's just it's the
magnitude of this season
is is bigger and it's very heavy for
everybody
going in i already know that like people
even leaving their families behind in
this is insane so
if we can just make it light-hearted in
there and just keep it game
and focus on our families and making it
through it i think i think it's gonna be
a good season
how do you think people will be mentally
and emotionally most of the time you
know you guys don't know what's going on
in the outside world but now you you
have this
this awareness of this big thing that's
going on in the outside world
and then you're going in there having
been quarantining yourself for months
and being in a bubble of quarantine
before you go in where is everybody's
heads at
and just basing it off my own head i
think everybody is going to be
a little bit excited right away to
actually be able to be in a group of
people
because none of us have been around
other people for a long time so i'm
thinking at first it's gonna be
like very exciting for everybody you
know like we are quarantining together
and we are stuck here and
it's okay some new faces yeah new faces
but at the same time everybody's going
to have their families and their friends
in the back of their minds you know and
everyone's going to want to do it for
them and be worried about them at the
same time so it's
it's going to be heavy and there's going
to be a lot of emotions
and i just hope we can kind of come
together as a group and be like listen
the world sucks out there but let's make
this the best we can
and get through it i mean even right now
you guys are quarantining in these
bubbles before you even go
in yeah does that make this
potentially the most intense season ever
this
is absolutely gonna be the most
intense high stakes craziest season of
all time just
big brother all-stars alone would be
enough to be
insane but the fact that there's a
pandemic going on outside at the same
time
and we're watching a bunch of people
quarantine together in a house compete
is gonna raise the stakes even higher so
i just can't believe i'm a part of it
i'm still
it's gonna be a wild ride i do wonder if
big brother contestants going through
the real corona quarantine
did better than the average person
because they kind of had already
experienced quarantine
oh yeah oh yeah it was it was nothing it
was just like right at home we've been
quarantined
way worse than this so when you first
found out that this was all stars
did you give anybody a text or a call
and say hey
have you been approached for this who do
you think you might see in there no
well first of all we weren't allowed to
do that because it ruins the game
and i just i kind of wanted to go in
with like a fresh slate you know what i
mean
i have relationships with people from
past seasons and other seasons
and if i see some of those people in
there let's make it work
but i don't want to base my entire game
off of my past relationship
because some people might be having
deals on the side and all that so i need
to wait
until i get in there and really focus
and kind of read the room
and see where everybody's at see who
else has ties
anybody you'd be afraid to see and
anybody you'd be excited to see
uh i wouldn't really be afraid to see
anybody
i really want to play against some of
like the goats
but i'm not really expecting to see like
dr will in there
or like dan or derek i'm hoping
to see some of them because i want to i
want to be on that level someday you
know
what do you want to prove to everybody
i mean i wouldn't say i have anything to
prove
i just think i have like a cool style
that i bring to big brother
and i know i put 100 of like my heart
and my soul into the game and
if that didn't come across to everybody
last time i want that to come across
everybody this time you know and i'm
gonna go in there and i'm gonna do my
best to make sure
i give it 110 this time and step it up
maybe i can pull out a win and
then i'll consider myself like one of
the better players but until then
i don't think i deserve that spot yet i
gotta earn it if you win
will you use that prize money on a ring
hey hey hey
that one's for me to know and you guys
to find out later
all right i really gotta ask you though
i mean you've spent a lot of this
interview talking about angela
i see her name on that sticker behind
you you love her
how serious is this is she the one for
you oh yeah man she is the one
that's that's my girl that's my best
friend that's my everything so
i mean honestly it's going to be
terrible being apart it is already
terrible
but if if you guys thought i was
dangerous last time when i was just me
now that i have her as my motivation i
feel like i can maybe be
like unstoppable which is thinking about
her all the time so
no i'm excited behind every man there's
a great woman and you got yours in your
head
that's right 24 7.
you